welcome to cloud on air
google cloud's live webinars we host
webinars every tuesday
and i'm i'm russ i'm here to talk to you
about grab-and-go
google's chromebook learner program
uh stand by after the session you can
ask questions and
we we have googlers on standby to answer
them for you
so first up uh google's grab and go
program it's a self-service chromebook
loaner program
uh before we get into the specifics of
the program i'm going to tell you a
little bit about
chromebooks in chrome os at google so
we're actually chrome enterprise's first
and largest customer we have the largest
lead of
chromebooks in the world um we manage a
mixed hardware ecosystem here at google
so
uh chrome os is just one component of
the the broader suite of applications we
have
we have linux mac windows you name it
whatever our users need to be
happy and productive and we're also
just another big enterprise we also want
to reduce costs we want to keep our
users productive and we want to make
sure they have the tools they need to
get their jobs done
the benefits that chrome os brings to
our ecosystem
break down into two high-level
categories so there's the user-focused
benefits
we found that our users are very happy
being able to switch between devices
work anywhere and just generally use a
platform that's made for working on the
cloud
on the business side we found that
chrome's baked in security features make
it
perfect for kind of making it
administrators a little bit happier with
the security state
and also reduce the burden of management
on these devices
so it's a great investment they're super
easy to manage and users love them
now it's important to keep in mind that
grab-and-go is just
a small piece of the broader chrome os
ecosystem
at google before we get into the
specifics of the program
um i do want to talk about the problem
that we were trying to address
uh i.t downtime so uh
i t downtime is actually a very very big
problem for enterprises
ihs market estimates that north american
companies
are spending around 700 billion dollars
a year
on broken devices i.t downtime things
like that
now that might be maybe a million
dollars for a small to medium-sized
business
or up to 60 million dollars for a larger
enterprise
that productivity lost time extends
beyond just the bottom line of the
company there's
also employee motivation corporate
reputation
and the pressure that it puts on it
teams so
really it downtime is a huge problem
that's why we started digging into this
problem in the first place
google's certainly not immune from those
same problems again we're just another
big enterprise
um the problems that we saw generally
broke down into these four categories
so the first was the fatal device error
so some software problem that rendered
your device unusable
maybe you forgot your laptop at home
maybe you lost it
uh maybe it's just not accessible for
whatever reason
you might be traveling to a different
location where you either don't want to
bring your device or can't bring your
device
and then the all-famous damaged device
maybe you've spilled coffee
into the keyboard of your laptop as you
rushed into the office in the morning
we've definitely all been there
so our first crack at solving this
problem was with a traditional lunar
program or what we call a traditional
loner program
so the employee experiences the problem
they come to the help desk seeking a
loaner device
they wait in line then they see someone
from the help desk the person from the
help desk prepares the device for them
checks it out explains how to use it the
employee takes the device
uses it probably with a lower
productivity than their usual device
and then they return it when they're
done again they have to wait in line
they have to talk to the it admin
they have to go through that whole
process the it admin takes the device
back
wipes it resets it does whatever they
need to do to prepare it for the next
user
and the cycle repeats now this was
definitely
helping solve the problem and we
definitely realized some gains from
having a loaner program like this but
it still wasn't cutting it for us um
somewhere around 10
of visits to our help desk were just for
checking out a loaner device which is a
huge amount of time that both googlers
and our it team were spending on this
every step in the process people were
losing time and it really wasn't a great
experience for anyone so
we took another crack at it that's when
we designed the grab and go program
we designed it with four core tenets in
mind first being it need to be
self-service
we didn't want to have all these it
admin interactions we wanted to
allow googlers to do this whenever they
needed sign in process need to be super
quick no waiting in line no setup no
nothing you just sign in and you're back
to work
return process need to be just as easy
and of course it needs to be 24 7.
let's dig into those core tenets a
little bit deeper
first up self-service the whole idea was
that you can help yourself
uh the physical manifestation of our
lunar program
is a shelf devices and signage so that
you understand how it works
uh these shelves where devices were
constantly charging are placed
throughout our offices
typically they're placed in areas of
high traffic or maybe outside of a help
desk where people kind of already
associate i.t problems going
on those shelves devices are always
charging so they're ready to go as soon
as you pick it up
there's a sign right above the shelf
that explains how to use the program so
basic things like just pick it up log in
and get going
we found that users had a lot of
questions about how the program worked
and uh they were kind of unsure of the
easy nature of it so having that sign
there really makes them feel a lot
better
and then of course on the devices
themselves we also brand them so that
people know
this is a loaner device and we answered
some faqs we put stickers inside the
laptop as well
for things like getting set up or how to
return the device both common questions
that we found with our users
one kind of invisible magic piece of
this is
as soon as a user logs into the device
we push a custom chrome companion
application to the device
and that reports back to us that that
user has signed in and it assigns it to
them and we'll explain that in a little
bit more detail
later in this presentation
the next piece quick sign in so like i
said users need to be able to sign in
get back to work quickly and it admins
didn't really need to be involved in
that
so chrome os actually provided a lot of
the key ingredients here
the things like chrome sync and google's
prolific use of g suite applications
made chrome os
an easy choice in this respect uh user
could just take it log in with their
corporate account and they're back to
work just like that
return process need to be just as easy
sign out
close the lid put it back on the shelf
plug it in
and you're done chrome os again provided
a key ingredient here
so we needed to create a system that
allowed devices to go from user to user
to user without it admins being involved
we didn't want to wipe these devices
every single time someone used them
so chrome os has this feature built into
it where
profiles are encrypted by default so you
don't have to worry about data going
from user
profile to user profile
and lastly 24 7 access mishaps certainly
don't stick to a schedule
neither do we this learner service need
to be out there barrier free for people
to use it 24 7.
now in the early days of designing this
program we often came back to the idea
of
can we just put chromebooks out there on
our charging shelf and not add all these
bells and whistles no signage no
automation
uh maybe not even chromebooks um so
that's when we started to dig into
well beyond those four core tenets what
things are really really important to us
in building out this program
so the first of those things the first
key ingredient that we identified was
chromebooks really add so much to the
equation
here's a list of a few things that we
think are important the first is
chromebooks scale really really easily
they're super easy to set up
takes about 10 minutes on average to
deploy a chromebook
and we could add devices to the fleet
very quickly because of that and kind of
scale up how many devices were out there
in addition security was top of mind for
us these devices weren't going to see it
admins all that often so we wanted to
make sure they were super secure
things like encrypted profiles automatic
white verified boot and sign-in
restrictions really important to us
we'll dig into those actually a little
bit more on the next slide
switching easily between devices was
also very important so
the best experience would be if you use
a chrome device as your primary device
and you're using a chrome device as a
loaner it was seamless
at google we used the chrome browser
quite a bit so that made it easy for
people on other platforms so if you're
using the chrome browser on say a
windows machine
logging into a loaner chromebook was a
very familiar experience
on top of that chrome sync made it so
that things like bookmarks and data and
settings
also made it onto that device making it
a very familiar field
grab-and-go chromebook models we we
found that
picking very durable models was was
important to the program being
successful
so we wanted enterprise grade devices so
that our users could be as productive as
possible
but we found what we called the rental
car effect so if you are using a loaner
device you didn't really treat it the
same as you would your own device
and we wanted to make sure all of our
devices could stand up to that wear and
tear of a loaner program
and last but certainly not least chrome
os's loaner program ready out of the box
the features that i talked about earlier
do need to be configured but it just
takes a few clicks in the chrome
management applications
so let's talk about those security
features that are so important to us
first there's system updates being
automatically downloaded and installed
on every device
this was a great peace of mind feature
for us and it made it
so that we didn't need to worry about
taking these devices in updating them it
would all happen while they were out
working with users only users on a
specified domain can log in to our
loaner devices
so only google.com users can log in and
we have guest mode disabled by default
but you can enable it we'll talk about
that more later
policy enforcement even after factor
reset was also important we didn't want
devices to walk off
someone to factor reset it and then it's
their device we wanted it to stay in the
loaner program
so auto domain re-enrollment was a key
feature that we relied on
uh user data being encrypted between the
the different profiles
was also key we needed these devices to
go from user to user as i mentioned
before
and lastly chrome os has baked in tamper
protection
it's called verified boot and that makes
sure that there's nothing funny going on
with
the os already on the device
design considerations so there are three
key ones here the first
is the signage that i mentioned before
all the signage and stickers that we use
are very intuitive very easy to
understand just in a minute of reading
it
the signs which i'll show a little bit
later have just three steps all the
stickers just have a few steps so that
you can quickly understand what's going
on with the program
the chrome companion app that i
mentioned before also pops up as soon as
you log in and gives you kind of some
handholding guidance on how to use the
program how it works
and it eases some of those fears that
users might have like do i need to check
this out do i need to talk to an it
admin
no it's all taken care of and lastly
follow-up details are emailed to the
user so
in the case that users have even more
questions maybe we want to tell them
what their return date is for that
device or maybe we want to nag them and
say hey you've held on to this for a
little too long all of that's
facilitated via email
automation this is another key key piece
of the of the experience now i've
mentioned the chrome companion app a few
times but
the whole brain of the system is a
custom app engine application
that we built that drives the whole
program now this makes
management of the program super easy and
just about hands off
that back end application tracks device
usage
attracts availability of each rack
charging rack and it also notifies users
if they need to return the device maybe
they need to
extend it or extend their loan or keep
it for a little bit longer
let's dig into this a little bit more so
the first piece of this
automation that's vitally important is
the chromebook we've already covered
that
the baked in features make chrome os an
easy and very important part of the
program
google's admin apis allow us to enable
key features to keep those devices
safe secure and usable by our users and
then one of the policies that's pushed
is actually that chrome companion app
you can push
applications via policy when that
application installs
as soon as the user logs in it then
phones home
to the app engine back end where uh
reporting is done where emails are sent
we already talked about a few of those
things
the other important thing that back-end
application does is integrate with
things like reporting systems
it works seamlessly with google's
bigquery and datastore and it allows us
to tie into things like ticketing
systems that we use internally
so does this work yes definitely we've
been really happy with our loaner
program internally at google
around a third of all google employees
use a grab-and-go device each year
that's roughly 275 loans per day and
growing
around half of program uses are to
remedy a true productivity blocking
problem
previously those problems may have taken
up to a day or more to resolve
so gone are the days of waiting weeks
for a replacement device or maybe
a day while the it department
troubleshoots your problem you're back
up and running
instantly now the other half of usage
is more for users that want some kind of
convenience so maybe they're
running between meetings and don't want
to carry a laptop with them or they're
traveling and they don't want to bring
their laptop with them
we found that this is a nice convenience
it definitely keeps people productive
and it's also been a nice perk for a lot
of googlers
and lastly we estimate that in its first
year of operation this program paid for
itself
and productivity time saved after only
50 days and now that includes our
capital investment the time we invested
into it and everything 50 days is a
great roi on this program
so a few of the use cases that i
mentioned earlier um
so there are actually three buckets of
use cases we've identified the first
is that productivity blocking use case
so those are the broken devices the lost
the forgotten devices
the places where you just wouldn't have
been working otherwise on the convenient
side i mentioned there is travel
on the go between meetings but this
third category
we found is very interesting which is
introducing chromebooks to your
organization
the grab and go program can be a really
interesting way to kind of break the ice
with users that
don't have a lot of experience with
chrome os it's a fantastic way to show
the power of chrome os
and also kind of save the day at the
same time so if you're looking to expand
your chrome os footprint at your company
this might be a fantastic way to do it
and have an easy win for the it
department
so why should you adopt chrome
enterprise grab and go
first and foremost reducing downtime
keeping your employees productive is
top of mind for us and it should be for
you too grab-and-go is also a technology
enabler it's an easy win for an i.t
department
and it makes your users a lot happier it
removes frustration stress
and it's really a fantastic safety net
at the bottom of many many broken
journeys
uh it's super easy to implement chrome
os has these fantastic features that you
can enable just by clicking a few
buttons
and we've made it even easier which i'll
give you some clues on that in a minute
and lastly it allows your it department
to focus on fixing problems rather than
handing out loaners
like i said earlier around 10 percent of
uh visits to our help desk were just for
loaner devices
and i'm sure that's true at other
companies offering a similar loaner
program
so this allows your team to focus on the
really tough aspects of it
and maybe the not so enjoyable parts of
inventory management
how to get started we made it super easy
the first thing you should do is go to
g.co
grab and go we have a white paper with
lots more details on how our loaner
program works so you can give that a
look you can also sign up for updates on
how the program is progressing and how
what we're sharing at any given time
and you can also access all of our open
source resources that we've made
available on github
at github.com google loner and now on
github we have everything from
code to instructions to setup materials
to even the images and assets that i'm
going to show you in just a minute here
so give those two things a look and
let's jump into
a couple demos here so the first thing
i'm going to show you
is a video demo of the
companion app that i've mentioned a
couple times here
this application that you're about to
see is the bare bones basic
out of the box experience this
application
is incredibly easy to set up incredibly
easy to customize and i'll go through
where those customization options are
later first thing that happens when you
sign in
you see this application pops up in the
bottom left-hand corner that icon shows
up
and this reader is the first thing that
you see let's get started it explains
how the program works
it gives you information on what the
program is and kind of sets you off in
the right direction
the next thing that we've included is a
survey that asks you maybe what you're
using the device for
that's one of the things that we use to
do capacity planning at google for our
loaner program so we think that's
important but
you can change this to however you want
it to be every screen that you see here
is fully customizable
the next thing is setting a return date
again fully customizable you can say
this is due tomorrow or you can say
let us know when you're going to bring
it back and the last thing here
before you go this is some return
instructions a lot of our users were
having trouble understanding how to
return the device it was a little bit
too easy so we wanted to give some
instructions
again fully customizable here so this is
the persistent app experience you can
get here by launching the application by
clicking on the icon
and you have a couple functions that you
can perform here one is extending the
loan
so you can click into it pick your new
return date
and tell us when you're bringing it back
the next thing that you can do
is enable guest mode on this device and
as i mentioned by default we disable
guest mode
but we found that a lot of googlers want
to use these devices to facilitate
things like interviews and have a
candidate do some coding on the
chromebook
so enabling guest mode is a nice way to
accommodate that
and then lastly you can mark the devices
returned uh this helps program
administrators
know this device is on its way back and
also helps that user kind of close the
loop on the loan
uh it gives them that last prompt to
bring it back
again return instructions helping them
understand how to bring this back what
they should be doing
in the next view here that you're going
to see there's another survey
this is a general csat survey you can
put whatever you want here
we found that csat was useful and
are you sure just confirming are you
going to bring the device back put it
back on the shelf
again fully customizable and that's it
so the next thing the user is going to
do is close the lid
bring it back to the shelf plug it in
and they're all set
the next thing i'm going to show is a
welcome animation now
this animation is something that we've
decided that we want to show in that
application instead of that static text
we found that animations for key
components of the workflow can be a
little bit more inviting
and we'll communicate key information a
little bit more effectively
both of these animations and the shelf
sign that i'm going to show you are
provided open sourced
on the gravingo application by default
welcome inviting image let's get started
it gives you a quick walkthrough of the
app experience itself enabling guest
mode
extending loan duration and accessing
the faq if you have more questions
you can go into the app at any time
and when you're ready to return again we
want to reinforce click that button
bring it back to us and this is just
looping again that you see here
the next animation that i'm going to
show is for the return flow
before you return it there's a couple
things we need to do
the first we found that a lot of our
users were leaving usb devices plugged
into their device so
we tell them pull those out bring it
back to the shelf
plug in the device having it fully
charged for the next user is useful
if you do distribute chargers with your
loaners return that
and you're all set now again
these animations can be shown in the app
itself as a part of the experience and
we think that's a great way to really
reinforce these key points
and the last piece here is actually the
shelf sign that we recommend using
you can see this just linked directly to
our github repository
and this is a really really easy flow to
understand you grab a device you log
in and you get back to work it's as
simple as that all the stickers that we
recommend using
for devices and understanding the
program a little bit better
are also in the same repository on our
github repo
so that's about all i've got in the demo
space for you
that's a wrap stay tuned we're going to
switch over to a live qa in just a few
minutes
thanks for watching so far we'll be
right back
thanks for sticking with us with us um i
think we're going to switch over to
questions now
uh so the first one that i see that's
come in is um
how many devices should i plan to buy
for my company's grab and go program
we don't have a specific number that we
recommend generally there are ratios
that you can stick to but
every business every enterprise every
use case is going to be a little bit
different
we found that some companies don't even
want to use this program as a loner
program it's more just a shared fleet of
devices for
uh maybe a manufacturing line worker or
something like that so keep the use case
in mind
but for a loaner program what we
recommend is
somewhere between one device for every
30 employees and one device for every 50
employees
so the 1 to 50 ratio will keep your
fleet pretty slim and it's going to be
highly utilized and you might have some
outages
one to 30 you'll add a little bit more
slack and you might see more of that
kind of convenience usage creeping in
for us that's okay we actually tend to
stray more toward the 1 to 30 side of
things but it's constantly changing at
google
so in summary do what's best for your
company and i would say
start small put a couple deployments out
there see how they're performing
adjust the numbers find your min and max
numbers and go from there
next up can i deploy a vdi solution with
grab and go
um yes so that's definitely possible um
we think that the beauty of this program
is that it's kind of
just chrome os and then we've added some
great management features and user
experiences on top of it
so it should be adaptable unless you've
got you know kind of an outlier
set up with your vdi solution but all of
this should work and
we've actually heard of some customers
planning to use this as almost the thing
client replacement
for their employees so definitely give
it a go
uh can i create can i recreate this
for my small business um yes definitely
um one of the the beautiful things about
open sourcing this is that anyone can
pick it up and run with it
there is a minimal amount of effort that
you'd have to put in to get the out of
box experience working
but this scales from even a small
business all the way up to a large
enterprise just like google so
give it a go do you supply chargers with
chromebook loans um
so initially we did now we actually
don't
for a couple reasons the first and
biggest reason is that
those chargers disappeared really really
quickly in the early days of the program
so
we were giving out chargers and devices
kind of on a one for one basis
we got all the devices back but we got
about 10 of the chargers back
and chargers are not cheap especially in
those numbers so
initially we elected to kind of scale
back how many chargers we were giving
out
later the company aligned on usbc
charging
and we kind of took our cue from the
broader company and said let's align all
of our devices in
the loaner program on usbc charging so
that people don't need chargers
typically
googlers will have a usbc charger at
their desk in conference rooms wherever
they're working
so they no longer needed a charger in
those cases
um that was a nice happy accident in the
end but i would say if you
if you don't have that uh kind of same
charging environment for your entire
company uh start conservative
and make sure that you're not spending
too much on charges like we did in the
early days
um do i need to use gcp for grab and go
out of the box yes
we use gcp we recommend gcp uh the
integrations are super easy
but again the beauty of it being open
source is that you can adapt this to
just about any use case if you don't
want to use gcp
pull out the gcp components and add in
the ones that you want what do you do
about users that don't return their
chromebook
can you talk more about how you
communicate with users
um so somewhere in the neighborhood of
two or three percent of loans go into
kind of like a lost or super long loan
state
for those users we have a couple
different approaches that we're
experimenting with right now
the first and one that's baked in by
default with the grab and go program is
nag mail so we'll send reminder emails
to bring the device back on our
recurring basis
and we found that those are surprisingly
effective
we've also experimented with locking
devices that have gone missing
but are still being used or
also copying managers on nag mails both
appear to be just as effective
if we're not seeing any activity on the
device if nobody's logging in if
nobody's using it
we consider it lost and the chrome
management suite
has these really great features that
allow you to essentially lock out a
device we do that for all of those
devices
if we're still seeing activity even
after those maybe manager escalations
and nag mails
we'll reach out directly and we're
starting programs now where
we're reaching out and we're finding
that a lot of teams that are hanging
onto grab-and-go devices for a long time
have a really fantastic use case for
just using chrome os so what we're doing
in a lot of those cases is just
buying chromebooks for those teams and
solving the problems that they're having
and
also getting our loaners back from them
how technical do i need to be to deploy
grab and go uh
quite technical but there's a bit of a
spectrum that exists here
so if you want all the bells and
whistles that come with grab and go yes
it is a technical deployment and it's
going to require you to know your stuff
but if you want to start small really
really small you don't need all those
bells and whistles
you can put chromebooks maybe at your
help desk and say hey if
you know you're working with an i.t tech
and it's taking a long time to get your
problem solved
just grab a chromebook that's a
fantastic way to get started
at google we wanted the bells and
whistles we wanted the program to manage
itself and we wanted it to be very
hands-off so we built this big
program that allowed us to do that so
how technical do you need to be for the
full bells and whistles
we recommend that you know a systems
administrator is involved
there is some gcp work you need to know
python typescript
you need to be comfortable working with
app engine applications chrome
applications
and maybe making some minor adjustments
to the open source application
if you want to go even further and
customize it for your organization you
might want to do that too and bring in
some developers
it's really up to you but just know that
there is a minimum requirement of
technical skill here
uh am i able to work with a partner to
implement gravity actually a great segue
here
so if you do want a grab and go program
but you don't have the technical skills
or maybe you just don't have the time to
customize and set up this application
yourself we do recommend that you go and
talk to the partner that you've worked
with
and ask them about grab and go we're
also in the process
of training several close partners of
google's
and showing them the way that google
does grab and go so they can reproduce
that for customers
so again if you fit that mold of you
don't want to do all this deployment you
just want to ask a partner to do it
definitely reach out have that
conversation and get things going
we're expecting to be able to publish a
list of partners that we've worked with
and that are ready to deploy grab and go
in the next few months
so i think that's those are all the
questions that i've had
um thank you very much for joining us
uh you should stay tuned for the next
session that's going to be cetv
first steps with apache kafka on google
cloud platform
thank you again and have a good one
you